thomas singer appareil vous êtes à rome
oui on soit quelque part j'ai reçu votre
bouquin du coup j'ai lu vous avez
couvert l'histoire depuis le début une
étudiante anglaise avait été victime
d'un meurtre à sienne qui sont soit
innocent soit coupable
on peut pas rester neutre quand je pense
au visage d'un an je pense toujours à
elizabeth may pour vous c'est jessica
réel l'histoire pendant tout le procès
ce qui est apparue séquelles jessica
était bien sûr la méchante et elisabeth
la gentille et qu'est-ce que vous filmez
d'affaires jusqu'à fuller vous faites un
documentaire un film je voudrais un
guide vous pourrez bien sûr j'ai envie
de parler très fonctionnel ça y est on
entend le ventre de la bête
si vous voulez le rencontrer c'est
possible et qu'on les écoute tu penses
que tu es la seule autorisée à faire un
peu d'argent avec cette histoire
qu'est ce qui se passe et pourquoi ils
accuseraient une personne innocente
seule une femme pourrait recouvrir un
corps alors que celui ci est déjà mort
mais jessica ltte une fille intelligente
ça fait pas d'elle un assassin vous avez
un motif la police et le parquet de
sienne ne condamne pas les bonnes
personnes
et vous vous en pensez quoi
oh
des classes